yo plan welcome to this video here I
made a mistake while her started the
video so slight delay down and Gibbons
tail is the apology i recently lost
against her I don't exactly remember
that game okay we got a Queen's Indian
are playing a somewhat modest line but
not a bad one this is some fairly solid
way to handle this with white um black
quite often goes a six to prevent not be
five but now it's probably not the end
of the world yeah i'm having a look at
the a6 phone so that he not so easily
and can move the edge rook and ninety
forever is an idea hmm yeah quite often
92 to g3 as an idea but I have the Queen
honey too wet probably not the best
possible way to player now that I think
of it hmm
yeah I really want the night on g3 to
have 95 as well okay this is a bit silly
but better to correct things than to
them yeah just stubbornly continue what
you had planned in the first place yeah
95 was an idea to play against c7 ok I'm
going here b5 wow that's not a move that
I expected it looks a tad weakening hmm
yeah maybe going for you for as an idea
I'll take this route because here i
wanted i wanted this look here for f3
hmm i just wonder if I'm be sure takes
DTX 92 and 5f three who it doesn't look
too great
yeah that's not so great but I have to
have some time here I don't they don't
think he's going to go see five okay he
does it immediately yeah not one very in
the world that the long diagonal here is
kind of a problem okay um not sure 94
maybe bishop divorce also decent looking
ya know they just you just wants to
prove that you can play a bullet game in
blitz well you can do that you can just
play instant moves all the time and
maybe get away with it
I'll try to get that pawn I'm really not
sure about this position it might be it
might be good for him he's got two
bishops against two nights but I have
ideas with nida fire and stuff so not
entirely sure what to make of this
Jonah the five is not yet a threat okay
maybe if I Drive I need to be somewhat
quick iam so what is this point there I
don't know try for Queens you form
okay night f5 or is that not doing so
much not not sure if this helped is
helping me but I can't maybe take the
sea foul him ok let's take first and
then think about it
yeah maybe first go there for whoopsie 7
so Luke c7 zouk e7 ah ok so I'm gonna go
for night f4 maybe not sure if I want to
trade really rather one to input rook on
g7 ok man let's allow the trade it's not
ideal but couldn't really can't find
anything particularly bad at high
morning night f4 or not probably not
this looks a bit trickier
check I mean it's quite clear that I
don't want to draw but I'm very much
done on time so this is some this is
something to chat well that makes things
easier black forfeits due to
disconnection yeah totally fits their mo
okay yeah blitzing out some stuff
without thinking at all and then
disconnecting at the end yeah that
Queenie to was a bad idea you should I
should just play Queen Queen situ in
this position I think this is also
through reticle line or maybe 92
immediately yeah this is it doesn't make
much sense now I did but it is correct
this yeah I think this is an equal
position this is trippy around equal
ideas before now he stopped that with
this rookie to see and now he really
went c5 him I don't know I was surprised
by the move but it of course also
activates pieces I mean black is
definitely all right here that's no not
not really a not really any question the
computer gives black 0.50 point for
something like that before I think that
was all pretty much okay this is this I
went here yet I don't know the next not
sure really about this because now i get
i get this trade in are the engine
actually gives this move yeah i had to
be quick and didn't see that shine yeah
here you cannot really get it back
favorably interesting position
40 page six hmm interesting well I
didn't see that I just saw that i will
get this get this back now and I was
glad to that I got rid of the Seaport
well here I felt that he is better with
the two bishops but it isn't entirely
clear because the scheme position is
somewhat weakened and now knight c6 is a
good movie am I was kind of a little bit
panicky here because of the time that's
all pretty much equal Queen a six now is
good for white probably I'm threatening
neither for then yeah didn't see that
can check yeah I wanted to play for when
I was just a bit anxious because of the
time this and I'll give give order to
give me to give g-force is just strongly
because it cannot take it and I'm
threatening to win it and well his
bishop is not a particularly great great
piece but as usually took three sections
and blundered his queen so I'm gas
sometimes thinking a bit does help
thanks for watching